how does a filmmaker decide what kind of
short to make
you should definitely make something
that you want to make
i always say and this is for shorts and
for features you know when people say
well what makes a good film i always say
there's three things the very first
thing is something you want to make
for shorts and for features you
shouldn't make something you don't want
to make you're going to be the prime
driver of this and you're going to live
with this for the rest of your career so
don't think you know
horror films are very popular so i
should make a horror film it's like no
if that's not who you are or what you
want to do this is the short film is
your chance to do what you want to do so
don't sell out because you think you
should do that no do something you
really want to do so the first thing is
make something you really want to make
then the second part is just make
something that other people want to make
so if you can't convince anyone to star
in your short or help you to help you
know direct it and or produce it or act
in it or
you know even crew on it if people
aren't so excited to help you on it that
might be your first clue that this is
not something really is ready to be made
at this period of time
or maybe you don't have enough money to
make it i know a lot of people have
written short scripts and you look at
you're like well do you have twenty
thousand dollars because if you don't
have that i don't think you're going to
be able to make this film
again we're so used to seeing features
that do all these incredible things that
we it's hard for us to realize well yeah
that has budgets of you know millions
and millions of dollars so if you wanted
to do something that was kind of like
that but only two mil two minutes long
still you're gonna need a million
dollars so you know do you have a
million dollars you got to scale back
and do what you can actually physically
do for a short film so something you
want to make something others want to
make and is makable and then lastly
this is the part that you can ignore not
ignore but something that other people
want to see
so you know just because you want to
make it and your friends want to make it
it could be that you know you're not
getting into festivals because it's just
not a film that people really want to
see
so um
i always say
there's a lot of people make short films
about alzheimer's and i'm always like oh
another alzheimer's short
it's a story that they really felt like
they wanted to tell and there's a lot of
older actors who love to do that film
too and you can get great actors and
great drama in the story and it really
could be moving
but we've seen that short over and over
and over again and you know in a
submission of like
20 short films
two of them will be all cyber shorts and
you're just like
we've seen it the audience has seen it
it's just overdone
so you know there are certain things
that are just overdone it used to be for
a while zombie shorts like everybody was
making zombie shorts i think because the
makeup was easy to do or accessible and
again there's inherent drama in zombies
right and maybe that's something people
really want to do they're like i want to
direct the walking dead so i'm going to
make a zombie short and you know having
said that there's some zombie shorts
that i absolutely adore and people did
crazy things with it like zombie prom
and
there's a great one called i love you
sarah jane so there's something i love
is zombie shorts but there's been a lot
of zombie shorts so you know yours has
to be different so that people don't be
like that's another zombie short
sure and what was the feature of
alzheimer's feature was it away from her
oh wasn't it alice was one too there's
been a lot yeah there's been some great
features but yeah i get it for short it
might be yeah but even now if you tried
to make another feature of that people
be like haven't we seen that 100 times
already sure sure there's certain topics
that are just you know you could argue
universal and always of interest and
again your specific version of it would
make it specific and not so universal
you know everybody has a different kind
of story with it
um so in the same way there's lots of
different ways you can do zombie shorts
so not talking you out of it i'm just
saying by the way
there's a lot of that however again like
coming of age aren't there a million
coming-of-age stories and each one is
different and unique so you should tell
your own coming-of-age story that you
really want to tell and quite often
students do because like what living
have they done coming of age is all the
living they've really done
so go ahead and make a coming-of-age
story and i'm sure it'll be you know
very moving and touching and something
you wanted to make and others wanted to
make there just might be a point where
people don't necessarily want to see it
because like
we've seen a lot of community shorts
sure or or about like a family member
but i know there was there's been a few
where there was one about a guy whose
dad was a musician and he kind of gave
it up to raise his kids and there was a
part of him that felt very resentful
about that and it was a great look at
how
this guy never really got to connect
with his dad because his dad always felt
like i gave up my art for you and and it
was the way it was done was was i mean
you had tears in your eyes
i love moving short you know so as much
as i'll try to talk filmmakers out of
something like i don't know don't do it
we don't benefit if it's moving i don't
care if i've seen a million of them
before i want to be moved and i want to
be touched and i want to hear a story
that the filmmaker had to tell despite
100 people telling them don't do it
there have been too many of them or
whatever
if you have something passionate you
want to say and do then it'll translate
onto screen and we'll see it and be like
wow even though we said oh we've got a
million of them we're only going to show
one we're going to show yours because
yours was so fabulous sure and but then
there's a danger and you could do it oh
my uncle joe's just great and everyone's
like
sure he's a sweet guy but what's where's
the arc here you know so that there is
you know i get my big pet peeve's
endings that so many people and this
what turns what was sketches a lot too
that there's just no ending and with
short films we really are critical about
the ending quite often there's a big
terrific twist at the end that takes you
completely just by surprise and
everything you've seen before you now
reevaluate um and those ten shorts tend
to do great because we're not expecting
that um but no matter what there has to
be reason that your short ends at that
time and that ending has to feel
satisfying to the viewers so you know i
think that's where a lot of people fail
too is that just peter's out there's no
real ending there's no last statement or
anything like that um it's just like and
it's over maybe because they ran out of
money or because the ending didn't work
and they just kind of cut back till they
found something they thought could
potentially work but ending is so
important
what if someone can't decide whether to
make a short film a feature film or a tv
pilot
so tv pilots i don't really have much to
say on that front because
it's not my specialty and it's also
tricky in this world i mean i think you
could make something that other people
will say oh that could actually work as
a pilot for concept for a tv show so it
wasn't like a 22 minute or 42 minute
full-on
legitimate pilot you know which again
people are used to expensive uh stuff on
tv so if you have those you have those
millions sitting around so you can make
a pilot that looks like a real pilot go
for it but you can do a part of it or a
little segment of it or a trailer of it
to give people an idea of what it could
potentially be
but for a short film or for a feature
film um you know
you can you can go ahead and make it
right nobody's gonna stop you from doing
it um and i shouldn't be just say don't
do a tv pilot if you know how to do it
go for it do it
again nobody stops you and that's what's
so fabulous it's like if you want to do
it and you think you know how to do it
go for it totally make it but i always
say too people can tell people can tell
from like watching two minutes of a 20
minute long film this person is
storytelling this person knows what
they're doing and they'll often say i
don't need to see the whole film i can
see that they know you know how to work
with actors how to deliver moving
moments etc and that can show people
okay now they're ready to make that
bigger piece
so don't feel like you have to do the
full
length thing
to have people appreciate what your
talent is or see that there's talent to
make you take the next step of
you know you don't have to make a low
budget feature to get hired to make a
feature there are many people who've
gotten hired to make a feature based on
a short film or just based on their
script by themselves you know by itself
that they can be a director for it um
you know i do believe in low budget
filmmaking and there's a great up no
again no one will stop you and that you
can make amazing things with a low
budget film
but i always think it kind of comes back
to money too you know
no matter how cheap you try to do it low
budget filmmaking for feature
that's a lot of money you know it's even
if you're skipping by with thousands
it's like do you have thousands
you can make a car or you could buy a
brand new car or you could make a
feature film that
and people aren't used to seeing so
cheap feature films too that's what's
also really difficult they're used to
more expensive films so sometimes they
don't see the value of what you're
making when you've done it so incredibly
cheap
i would say you know a short film that
was really short but shows your talent
and shows what you want to do is more
worth your time and effort and money and
so you know again i don't think you can
make a short film for no money
whatsoever you can make a short film for
500 you can make a short film for a
couple of thousand dollars quite often i
teach and some of my students
underestimate how much money they have
to put into it
especially about posts
now when you're a film student you can
often get things to help you with post
but the difference between something
that you just shot on your iphone with
no post and something that you do proper
post on
world of difference
so you know people underestimate the
money that you need for post production
and then they offer
underestimate the amount of money you
need if you're going to send your film
off on the festival circuit
that's also not free
so all of a sudden it's like let's say
you had five thousand dollars which i
would love to have five thousand dollars
to spend on my art um you know i'd
rather you make a short film
for
three thousand dollars including all
your posts and save two thousand dollars
to send it off on the festival circuits
where you can actually go and attend
these festivals and you know
because they're not going to pay you
to if the festival's not your back door
they're not going to pay to fly you out
or put you up but you may want to do
that and then you know you need money to
do that so i would highly recommend when
you're budgeting put money for post and
put money money for festivals if that's
something you want to do
what if someone says i'll do my own post
a lot of people do think they can do
their own post because you know that's
the miracle of the the computer now that
so many elements are there and you can
in the same way you can write your own
script or shoot your own script but i
always say like it's a world of
difference if you have somebody shoot it
be a dp for you so why wouldn't you also
have somebody edit for you and be there
give their skills for that and why
wouldn't you have somebody do their
post-production sound
because it's amazing how much
post-production sound can add to the
production value of your film sound is
everything people will forgive things
that don't look that great but if the
sound is good it brings it up incredibly
and makes it so much more professional
and a lot of people want to help you you
know a lot of post-production places if
you approach them and you're only asking
for help on a five-minute long short and
you have time
you're like whenever if you can do it in
your spare time sometimes you can get
professionals to help you on these
things for not that much money or you
pay like a regular client if you have
that money you can get top not i know a
lot of short filmmakers who have
skywalker sound do their sound
it's doable you know so
if you have the money frankly in
filmmaking if you have the money a lot
of things are possible that's true
but don't skip on post and don't skip on
marketing